تضيق الارض على اهلها وما ضاقت البلاد
يوما
ميليشيات الحوثي على مدار السنوات الثماني
الماضيه تحاصر محافظه مارب اليمنيه
واعمالها مزقت بنيه ساكنيها اطفال في ربيع
العمر اثقلت كاهلهم هموم الحياه التي صعب
على ذويهم من قبلهم حملها
نقص في الغذاء او بيئه وامراض ومصاعب
اقتصاديه جميعها ازمات يكافحها اكثر من
مليونيه من اجل البقاء على قيد الحياه
خلال اشهر الشتاء الطويله وسائل التدفئه
شبه معدومه ففي النهار شمس خجول وفي الليل
ويل وبرد قارس تقرير صادر عن مكتب الامم
المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه كشف ان
اكثر من 21 مليون شخص بحاجه الى المساعدات
الانسانيه حاليا في وقت تواجه المساعدات
صعوبه في الوصول الى المخيمات
بظل الحصار المفروض من قبل ميليشيات
الحوثي
غرباء في ارضهم
واصبحت حجاره الوطن مكانا لاستراحه قصيره
ربما قبل السير على طريق المجهول